foreign
okay
good morning everyone i wish we weren't
wearing masks so we could see
how exciting it is to come before you
today
with joe biden having the tremendous
mandate
that he has and that
[Music]
pretty soon the hyphen will be gone from
vice president to
president-elect joe biden
it's a happy day for our country
because joe biden is a unifier because
he is determined to bring
people together because he respects all
points of view and as he has said i ran
as a democrat i'll govern as president
for all the people whether they voted
for me or not
so i am so
officially pleased with the outcome that
is
imminent and also personally delighted
because of the quality and caliber of
leadership that joe biden will provide
this morning it is clear that the biden
harris ticket
will win the white house his election is
historic
propelled by the biggest vote ever in
the history of our country
73.8 million and counting
americans the most votes ever received
by any presidential ticket in history
president-elect biden has a strong
mandate to lead
and will have a strong democratic house
with him
and many democrats in the senate this
has been a life or death fight for the
fate of our democracy as he says the
soul of our country
we did not win every battle in the house
but we did win the war
in 2018 we won 40 seats 30
30 or 31 of them in districts where
trump had won before they were in trump
districts
in preparation for the 2020 election
i said to people you have to help us
they say oh you've won
let's just do the senate and the white
house i know we won in districts
trump districts with trump not on the
ballot
in the next election he will be on the
ballot
and that makes winning those districts a
steeper
climb i'm pleased that we've
overwhelmingly won those districts
not all of them not all of them
but next time he won't be on the ballot
it is uh
one of the reasons we were able to win
so many seats was because of the caliber
of leadership of our members uh
some of them won some a few did not all
of them
excellent and i hope that some of them
will reconsider
uh will consider going at it again
as you all know the right to vote is a
sacred right in our country
and having that vote counted as caste
is uh the fundam foundation of our
democracy
so we must be patient and said people be
calm
said this monday tuesday sunday monday
to
be calm be confident
be patient and the votes are telling the
races
are uh called we look forward to
continued victories and house races we
have some out there
and we look forward to progress for the
people which was our agenda
and 18 continues to be for the people
lower health care costs
bigger paychecks by building
infrastructure american the greenway
cleaner government hr1 which will be the
first
on the agenda in january again
it will be hr1 while we prepare for the
new biden administration
we must also move swiftly for a new
coronavirus relief bill
to kenya that we want the republicans
to come back to the table the white
house the leadership whatever
um 100 for two days in a row over 100
000
cases were reported
the imperative to act could not be
greater over nine and a half million
nearly nine million people infected
nearly a quarter of a million deaths and
tens of millions on unemployment
again i'm calling on the administration
to come back to the
table congress is also committed to
to passing an omnibus appropriations
bill
this is the core of our work
in the in the lame duck when we don't
have a pandemic
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and infecting millions
and uh making people food insecure
housing insecure and the rest but our
responsibility
to keep government open to have an
omnibus
bill and we intend to do that not a cr
and we want to be able to do so in a way
that
gives confidence that
we will have government open and
continue
to be rather than having a cr
so sadly instead of crushing the virus
it appears that the trump administration
will use its final moments
in office and a desperate last step to
destroy every possible protection for
american
health and well-being so many people
have said to me and perhaps some of you
along the way
what damage do you think that trump will
do between
losing the election and the swearing the
inauguration of joe biden
maybe you didn't phrase it quite that
way but that's how i heard it
and we knew that he would be up to
mischief
separate apart from trying to destroy
the credibility of our elections which
we
criticize other nations for doing and
now we
uh all enemies foreign and domestic
making assault on our elections well we
have one domestic
but apart from that on the policy side
which is why we are here
people asked that question
what will he try to do that is harmful
and
one this week
they showed their hand we had suspicions
of it but couldn't speak publicly about
it because
until they went public this week the
trump administration put forward a
radical new rule
that would make regulations from the fda
and other
health and human services agency
automatically sunset
unless the agencies undertake a
cumbersome time consuming process
to renew them this is a time when we
need
full attention of the fda on the
development and approval of vaccines
this is an opportunity cost but it is
a reflection of their disdain for
science
and governance you know they've been
messing with the whole process of the
fda
trying to to uh diminish the importance
of
of um the trials that are necessary
to approve efficacy and safety
of a vaccine the lame duck rules this
lame duck trump rule seeks to paralyze
government and generations of
life-saving protections
and try to burden the new president
elected by the american people
right out of the gate for the trump
administration wealth was to seek this
regulation uh rule beyond
hhs to other agencies as well people
have been asking for a while as i said
what can he do clean air clean water
food safety
you name it this is a dream of the
radical right wing
first they started the recently one
undermining the civil service
and now they're trying to say unless we
ex
review these all of these
regulations they will be sunsetted now
we do believe that
regulations should be subject to review
that's not any objection that's part of
the process but there is
there is a way to do it and it the way
to do it is not to first zero in on the
fda at a time when we're trying to
achieve a vaccine for the people and
this is uh
this is the work of the energy and
commerce committee and that's why i'm so
glad
and honored by the presence of the
distinguished chair of the energy and
commerce committee
uh you'll hear from him about this this
i i refer you to the
national register of november 4th
the day after the election they put this
uh destructive rule in the congressional
record
more from my distinguished chair thank
you mr colon
for coming down to be here for this
conversation which is very important to
the health and well-being
of the american people with a respect
for science
for governance especially at a time of
pandemic
when the fda should be focusing on a
vaccine
and not on a heritage foundation agenda
mr mr chairman thank you madam speaker
and and let me say like you and i think
like all democrats and i think most
americans uh
it's a very happy day because we we do
believe
it's quite clear that joe biden and
kamala harris will be
our next president and vice president
and so
we can't help but be happy about that as
the speaker obviously as and i
am but i just also want to commend uh
the speaker for still
stressing so much that we have to
crush this virus which he has been
saying now for so many months uh and of
course you know
i think the last time i was here with
her we talked about the need for
robust national testing uh tracing
uh and treatment which is in the heroes
act in which she
uh kept insisting on as she negotiated
uh with the white house she realizes
uh i think as most of us do that we're
never going to
get the economy back on foot we're never
going to create
jobs and we're never going to make this
country strong again unless we can
crush the virus and she's just you know
like a laser beam keeps insisting that
that's
so crucial and as she mentioned you know
the numbers
the virus continues to spread i mean
yesterday
more than a hundred and sixteen thousand
americans
contracted cover nineteen it was a one
day
record since the pandemic began so when
the speaker says
that this has to be crushed it's because
it's part of the reason is because it's
getting worse
and we have to address it and the sad
thing and that's you know kind of my
role here today is to get into more
specifics
about what the trump administration is
doing what president trump is doing
in this lame duck in these last few
months uh is
exactly the opposite in other words
rather than trying to
uh help with the scientists with the
health experts with
those um career servants who have been
helping us try to come up with a
response to this virus
uh he's trying to undermine it all he's
trying to
make it more difficult for us to uh to
crush the virus he's making more
difficult for those health experts
to speak out and to even be there at all
to help with this effort and that is so
unfortunate he's moving the exact
opposite direction
of what uh the speaker and most people
say we need
in order to crush this virus and um
so i just wanted to talk a little bit
about uh these two things that the
speaker mentioned one is this
executive order threatening the civil
service employees
a lot of the people who are uh who are
helping us uh within hhs
and other agencies um are career civil
servants
and he issued this last-ditch effort to
fire
uh career civil servants on october 21st
this executive order
and you know this includes people at the
fda and the cdc as the speaker mentioned
and basically um says that over the next
month or so the president uh and his
administration could put out a new
schedule
classifying career civil servants for
example somebody like dr fauci
um as not essentially non-civil service
employees who could be fired you
remember that
at one of his rallies just before the
election he suggested that
he might fire fauci after the election
dr fauci is an example of the type of
person who could be fired
under this executive order and possibly
even
be replaced uh by people like dr atlas
who are not qualified
um you know to actually uh deal with
this virus effectively because of their
because of their lack of background or
their or the policies
um and all of this before
uh he leaves office on january 19th now
some said well
is he really going to fire these people
i don't know
but he but the very fact that um that um
this is in place is a threat right so in
other words
it's either i'm going to fire them or
i'm going to threaten them with the fact
that
if they speak out and do things contrary
to what i want to do
with regard to covet 19 uh then they'll
know that they might lose
their job they might lose their civil
service job so effect
is it's really basically the same thing
then the other one is the
that the speaker mentioned is this uh
rule change
uh that was put in place he issued a
proposed rule
uh just this wednesday that could be
finalized my understanding by
early december and what that says is
that
there's something like 2500 regulations
within health and human services this is
particular to health and human services
but we may see it with other things
that says that if any regulation has
been around for more than 10 years
uh then you have a period of time to
justify it
otherwise it expires and sunsets now
these are all regulations that deal with
um you know food safety um
um you know what uh approval of drugs
which has been such a controversy
because you know he's always been trying
to approve these drugs that we know the
scientists think
really are not effective and
beyond that though it also diverts
resources in other words if the staff
who are
working to crush the virus has to be
diverted to justify and you know
spend all their time dealing with this
regulations that they would not want to
sunset
it's um it's also a question of staff
time that takes away from
our ability to actually deal with the
virus the comment period for that closes
december 4th and he could actually
uh then put it in place and start this
whole process
to undermine not only the regulations
that now are over 10 years
old but others that might become 10
years old later
you know during the biden administration
so
we're just trying to emphasize you know
why is this president doing these things
that
undermine our ability to crush the virus
rather than working with the speaker
and trying to put together a plan some
you know like the heroes act
that would make a difference and
actually effectively crush the virus so
i just want to come conclude by saying
this
we need the scientists and we need the
public health experts
we need to scale up the testing the
contact tracing
the treatment um this is going to be
unfortunately is likely to be a dark
winter and it just doesn't make any
sense for the president to use this
short time that he still has left to
undermine
the national response it's also an
insult to these civil servants
um and one of the things that we
certainly are going to do because i'll
go back to the committees again if i
may miss madam speakers we're going to
spend our time in
energy and commerce and the other
committees trying to shore up
these agencies like hhs cdc fda that he
has tried to dismantle
for the last four years morale is very
low but i want everyone who works in
these agencies to know
that we as democrats speaker pelosi
joe biden our next president we're on
their side we are committed
to crushing this virus we are going to
support the public servants
we're going to work with obama
administration to undo the damage
and ensure that civil service
protections remain in place
and that we have a national response to
the virus and thank you for
all that you do madam speaker thank you
mr chairman i do want to commend you for
the testing tracing treatment
space mask wearing etc that is in the
heroes act that was a product of your
committee under your leadership
as well as working with scientists about
what really
is necessary to crush the virus so that
we can
put our children safely back in school
open up our economy that's what we
really need to do
but we need to do it safely to a further
to a couple of points that you made
in terms of the civil service civil
service
is a very important part of the
democracy it takes a politics
out of the performance of civil servants
it is about public service being a noble
calling
but if those civil servants are directed
by political appointees to make certain
scientific decisions or else they will
lose their jobs
that is uh undermines the purpose
of uh safety and efficacy in terms of
of fda but also the health and
well-being of the american people
i want to commend peter marks the head
of one of the centers at the fda for
an important op-ed he had i think about
a week ago
talking about how the scientists were
going to stick
with a plan to do this in a way that
gives people
confidence in the vaccine that would
come forward because the vaccine is only
as effective
as its merit of course but also how
people will
take it the vaccine is a big hope for us
but it's not the only way for us to stop
the spread of the virus but it is an
essential way
for us to curtail the further further
spread
so again i thank you for your leadership
in that regard
and the idea that you you referenced it
until the no january 19th is the date
that they want this
all done by january 19th
can it be undone yes but it takes a
great deal
of time and effort to undo which took a
lot of time and effort
uh to uh make matters worse
in terms of uh approvals and et cetera
at the fda
so without a please to take any
questions madam speaker you open by
talking about this big win and it
appears joe biden might have in the
popular vote and so forth
but in that same election in that same
environment you're going to end up
losing seats off your majority
what does that tell you about what the
american people want from their congress
we lost a few seats uh but as i said
we won those seats in trump districts he
wasn't on the ballot he
is now i think that the uh
what happened with the democrats for
congress across the country
helped contribute uh to the biden's
success
so we're very proud of to be part of
that mandate
very proud of that what i rather have i
have the utmost uh respect for the
members whose districts were almost
insurmountable with trump on the ballot
uh
i do believe that we'll be in with biden
in the white house
and a democratic congress and hopefully
a democratic senate we'll see
uh in january we'll be able to do great
things for the american people as i said
we've lost some battles
but we won the war we have the gavel
we have the gavel you don't see any sort
of
policy or any kind of corrective message
from the american people there at all
no i do think that we should always be
uh evaluating and respecting what the
people
have to say i myself uh think that
uh and as i've said this to members over
and over again
income and equality income the
disparities in income and equity in our
country must be
addressed and everybody must be at the
table
to do that that's something that frank
has chairman pallone has
worked on from the perspective of new
jersey and his committee
so we have to go to that place people
are concerned about
uh the threats of their jobs from
technology from
trade from other people
just newcomers to our country and we
have to show them this is not a zero-sum
game
somebody's success here is not taking
away from your success there
so i see this as a tremendous
opportunity
a tremendous opportunity where people
are respectful
of people's opinions the diversity of
opinion
and uh uh again some members had some
uh concerns about what happened in their
district but most of people expressive
concerns
one most of them won and we had no
opportunity cost
spreading a wide net uh i was
disappointed that we didn't win some
seats in texas i'll be very honest about
that
but nonetheless um we're paving the way
we're paving the way we made our
investments we've won the
we held the house that was our goal if
we could win more that would be good
uh we're still in the hunt on a number
of seats right now
so we can have this conversation
probably next week with some numbers
but for right now uh
safely the gavel was in the hands of the
democrats safely we have
the prospect momentarily if not
happening while we're here
of president-elect joe biden vice
president-elect
kamala harris yes good morning thank you
how do you agree with the morning i
always get the front seats here i don't
know
a few weeks ago okay
how do you progress and this is
something i asked you about last week in
some of these philosophical differences
in your office
when obviously it's going to be more to
the left and from a governing standpoint
if you're going to get something done
with the senate regardless of its dr
or the white house that legislation has
to be
more in the middle how do you sort that
out with these pressure points at both
ends of your car well let's just say
this it's not both ends of our
caucus our caucus has its differences i
would not want to lead
uh in a caucus that was a rubber stamp
a rubber stamp lock step caucus
that's called republicans we are the
democratic party
and we have several exuberances in our
midst and that is representative
of the districts that people come to
congress
to serve and we respect that but
our unifying principle and your
girlfriend is
america's working families everybody is
there to make progress for america's
working families i always say
in terms of the children our children
our children our children their health
their education the economic security of
their families
a safe uh healthy environment in which
they can thrive including from
gun violence and a world at peace in
which they can reach their fulfillment
so about the families the kitchen table
issues
nobody is more attuned to that or
connected
to america's working families than joe
biden as president of the united states
so i think you will see as we build
consensus we don't
govern from on high we build consensus
not everybody that doesn't i didn't say
unanimity i said consensus
and uh i feel i feel pretty i see it as
an opportunity
i do say and i have said publicly
i represent san francisco very proudly
and some issues that would be wonderful
in my district are just not
winning issues other places in the
country that we have to win
that doesn't mean we curb our enthusiasm
for our
boldest perspec progressive agenda
but it does mean that we recognize if
we're going to win
in other places in the country common
ground
with the respectful of what works in my
district for me
but and other members in their district
but also respectful
for how it works for members in their
district and frank has a variety
of points of view in new jersey did you
want to speak to that well i mean i
think you can maybe
use new jersey as an example of what the
speaker is saying right in other words
we had
four front line members who
basically over the last two election
cycles took back
uh republican districts for democrats
these were republican districts
you know you look at the ncic or
whatever performance they
they leaned republican by anywhere from
two to five or six percent
and over the last two election cycles we
captured them
uh would i have liked to have uh you
know jeff andrew lose
and he may still lose actually he may
still lose
sure and then that would have been uh a
net gain it may still happen
but i take pride in the fact that we
were able to keep
these four frontliners that took
republican seats over the last two
cycles to contribute to a democratic
majority so
you know we stand here today i stand
here today with the speaker
joe bond is going to be president we
retain our majority
we've reelected and using new jersey
again you know a lot of these
members in districts that were for trump
in the past
so we're very proud of the fact of our
success and we have more opportunity now
because we have the white house as well
as the house and maybe even the senate
depending on what happens in georgia
welcome to my world we always have
we always have a beautiful uh dynamism
in our caucus but no i think people are
now
some people
i i would say we have a healthy
difference of opinion within our caucus
but not in any way to be problematic in
how we legislate
what the conversation was about what is
the winning message
outside and the message in the districts
that we have to win
is the message that unifies us a message
for america's working families
and everybody knows that
madam speaker the previous four
presidents clinton
uh bush obama and trump entered their
first year
with their party fully in control of
congress
the house and the senate how much do you
have to trim back the ambition
knowing that at best it's a 50-50 senate
and some think that the republicans are
favored in georgia
and you still have majority leader
mcconnell well i
i'm you know how many times have you
heard me quote lincoln
public sentiment is everything with it
you can accomplish almost anything
without it practically nothing and that
is uh
what i think is going to save the day
the public wants the virus to be crushed
they want
the economy to be open they want
children to go to school
safely the public wants a big jobs bill
and i don't care if you're in a san
francisco
michigan alabama wherever it is
people want jobs they want jobs
and that is when we talk about the
health and well-being of the american
people
job security is an important factor of
health
for those people so as we go forward
with a
uh infrastructure bill that is usually
not
partisan it isn't partisan and we're
going to blanket the country
with a build back better as joe biden
calls it we called it moving america
forward
we have a great deal in common between
those two agendas
and we think that you know when we did
for the
for the people remember we did that in
2018.
we weren't looking for a fight for
lower the cost of prescription the
president said he would do that
he said he was going to negotiate like
crazy to
to uh lower the cost of prescriptions by
having negotiation
i'm going to fight like crazy for
negotiating crisis okay
he didn't but he said that and that was
common ground
he said he wanted to build the
infrastructure of america
every conversation i had with him
starting
congratulating him and then after that
every conversation before he was
president and
in months after i want to build the
infrastructure i want to build the
infrastructure
until it came time to make the tough
decisions about paying for it and the
rest
and then he stomped down the room so
those were two
areas that he had espoused
in the campaign so we weren't as again
we were looking for
what was the most uh
impactful initiatives to affect people
on their kitchen table issues
the cost of healthcare etc preserving
the pre-existing condition benefit how
many times you talk about that
never did anything bad
look the republicans are taking a lot of
time saying how much they support the
pre-existing medical condition
well let's just see what the court does
there because that really
what that will be um and that's frank's
purview as well
in terms of the do you want to speak to
the health issue
well again i think that um you know if
you listen to what the republican
leadership says
uh in the house and the senate they you
know they say they want everybody to
have
health insurance they they say we're
going to repeal the aca but we're still
going to make sure people have health
insurance well i don't believe that
because i think the aca
is the most effective way to accomplish
it
but you know whether the courts
undermine the aca or certainly the
president has
uh i think there's a recognition with
both sides of the aisle
that we need to have as uh close to you
know 100
or however close we can get of americans
covered
so i think there's opportunities to work
with them
uh to deal with this you know hopefully
the the court doesn't
repeal the aca because that would be
hugely tragic for
for for the country but it's it's
certainly possible to work with them
on a number of these health issues and
we and we will and now we have the upper
hand because we have the president so i
think that
they're going to have to come a lot
closer to what we want
uh than to whatever president trump
wanted which i don't even know what he
wanted but
speaker on this score again because um
this is where we go from here and we
want to unify
joe biden as i said is the great unifier
where are the issues that we can find
as much common ground as possible now if
we're talking to our supporters in the
labor movement
jobs if you're talking about the poorest
people
reverend barbers poor people crusade and
all that
jobs everything in between jobs
jobs jobs a four-letter word and that is
uh
that is where we should be focusing and
health
jobs education for our children
and we have to show with our initiatives
for example
for example the timetable that our
planet is on
the climate issue is a big issue for us
it's also a jobs
issue it is we can create good paying
green jobs
be preeminent in the world in
green technologies as we
advance it as a health issue clean air
clean water
as a national security issue to protect
the habitat and the resources
and prevent some of migration that
causes unrest
as well as a moral issue so but when
we're doing it we have to have everybody
at the table so that people are not
afraid
of the future because it is inevitable
the future is inevitable we will
have to address the climate growth
technology
has an inevitability to it we have to
address what it means when you're having
precision farming and
and robots in the assembly line and the
rest
trade it we are a global economy there's
just no
getting around that and we want to be
because we want markets
for our products but people are
intimidated by that and we want to make
sure that
again as i said earlier it's not a
zero-sum game
your section wins your section loses no
how do we
go down this path together as i say i
see everything as an
opportunity and that opportunity is
greatly enhanced
by joe biden and his knowledge of his
vision for our country
his knowledge of the issues his
strategic
thinking about how to get it done and
his connection
heart to heart with the kitchen table
concerns of america's working things
well the same speaker
speaker does the election change your
strategy at all republicans are out
today saying there's good jobs numbers
let's do a smaller package now does that
appeal to you at all with the fact that
vitamins
no it doesn't appeal to me at all
because they still have not agreed to
crush the virus
if you don't crash the virus we're still
going to have to be dealing
with the consequences of the virus and
that's why we have said
the three pillars of our bill crush the
virus
honor our heroes that's our state and
local over a million people have lost
their jobs already in state and local
teachers and people in education etc
because
of the funds that have been used for to
address the virus and lost revenue
because of the virus
so no that that is a that isn't anything
that
that they that we should even be looking
at wasn't the right thing to do before
by the way while they refuse to sign up
for the science the testing initiative
which is what science says we need a and
they refuse to give an earned income tax
credit to poor families
who to keep them out of poverty working
families working poor family keep them
out of poverty where eight million more
people
have gone into poverty as the covet
money has run out
they still insist on having 150 billion
dollars
for the wealthiest tax break for the
wealthiest people
in our country so we are different we
have there's a difference between
democrats and republicans
we have a responsibility to find our
common ground
stand our ground where we can't but make
it clear to the american people what the
choice is
because public sentiment as i said
lincoln said is everything
but sentiment cannot weigh in unless
people know
for us now the fact that we have the
president of the united states
to speak to the american people in these
terms
is such an advantage for us to be able
to work together in a bipartisan way
rather than the republicans
mischaracterizing what we're trying to
do
in the in the congress of the united
states again i see as an opportunity i
think joe
biden has a big mandate a bigger mandate
than john f kennedy when i was in school
and a bigger mandate than others uh
it's it's pretty exciting for the
country because he respects every single
person
in our country certainly every single
person who voted
and we respect all of them and it is uh
uh we have challenges that need to be
faced
because of the future which is
inevitable and all that it contains
but we want people to know that the
decisions about it start
at the kitchen table and emmet out not
at the corporate boardroom
and trickle down thank you all very much
okay jake